Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 70th Anniversary!
BAU BAU!
Episode 70.
It feels like just the other day, you know, was like the 12th episode.
Right!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us, Ruffians.
Not just today, but for all the other episodes of FUWAMOCO Morning that you've been here.
The 70 mornings we're able to start you out with!
Right!
Well, and hopefully many many more from here on.
But, maybe this is your first morning joining us.
Well, to explain about FUWAMOCO Morning, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's a very happy FUWAMOCO Morning.
Almost a weekend too, right?
Extra, extra happy.
Yeah, so many episodes of Great Mornings.
BAU BAU!
I'm sorry to put a bit of a downer on our 70th episode, but there's been another Pero Sighting.
There's too many recently, Ruffians.
More Pero Sightings and Misunderstandings.
Well, two bad things.
I guess... Less bad things is better, but... Less bad things is better, okay?
Well, where was Pero spotted?
Let's see!
Well...
I guess Pero kinda got a bit hungry during his travels and was led here by the good smell, maybe?
That makes sense.
They look pretty good.
Yeah!
They're like takoyaki, but ebi-yaki.
So I guess instead of tako, ebi.
Ah, cool!
I guess maybe some people prefer shrimp to octopus.
You know, that's one of the great things about takoyaki.
You can just put in whatever you want most.
Moco-chan, what would you want to put into it next?
I like putting beni shoga in.
It's not meat though.
Beni shoga is just like a pickled ginger, but it's red.
It's red.
It's different from, you know, the juicy ginger.
But it's not meat.
Natto, no!
You could, but...
If it's fun and it's yummy, then it's good!
Pudding!
Onions!
Pizza!
Pero?
Pero Yaki?
I don't know.
Pero is more like the Bakudan Yaki sounds.
They're really big ones.
Yeah, it's like a big takoyaki.
Big!
But, yeah.
A bit difficult to eat.
Yeah, but as for liking shrimp or octopus more, I don't know if Pero really has any preferences.
I think he probably just wanted some yummy food here, right?
I guess he probably would like it more if it was pudding, huh?
Pudding-yaki?
If that's the case, he could have that, I guess.
Crumbly.
But you didn't give him one though, right?
Cause you know, if you feed him... Chaos.
Well, hopefully he just continued on his way and your stomach wasn't affected.
Right!
Hopefully.
Good luck with the FWM!
BAU BAU!
That's cool.
I wanna do that.
Can we take over for a day?
Yeah!
Ichinichi Tenjou!
That way hopefully we can keep Pero away.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Very very soon, something cool is gonna be coming out.
Do you remember what that is?
Well!
It's hololive English's cover of this song, Minecraft!
It's coming out really soon!
Yeah, it's premiering on Bae Senpai's channel at 7pm PT tomorrow during our Thief Simulator 2 stream.
I'm kind of disappointed.
I wish we could have been there for the premiere, but FUWAMOCO, we kind of... And then, it's a bit tricky when we're mid-game.
Can the stealing stop for a moment, Moco-chan?
We'll have to see.
But we hope that you'll make sure to be there in Tequila, okay?
Don't forget!
You'll miss out if you forget, okay?
This is why we're reminding you, okay?
It's a really, really emotional song and we're just really so happy and thankful to be included.
Let's all make sure to put it into our calendars, okay, Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
There's also something cool going on, but Ruffians!
You know that FUWAMOCO, we kinda, we like figures.
Anime figures.
But, do you?
Ichiyo!
Ichiyo.
Yeah!
I really like figures!
You know, I still remember my first figure ever.
It was actually by Good Smile Company.
I feel like Good Smile Company didn't have that many figures still out back then.
I don't know!
But I still love her very very very much.
Yeah, well, actually, Good Smile Company currently has a very special survey out to celebrate the 5th anniversary of the POP UP PARADE series!
Ah, the figure line!
Do you have any POP UP PARADE figures?
Ruffians, maybe.
With this survey, Good Smile Company, they want to know what characters you want to see in the series next!
So, that means Ruffians...
This is your chance!
If you want to see us FUWAMOCO as POP UP PARADE Figures, please let them know, okay?
Be passionate!
Passionate!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Papa Pre FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
Let's probably use some more words, don't you?
Words are good.
Yeah, but also, you know what?
If you answer this survey, you could also get a chance to win five purple parade figures of your choice too!
Let them know, okay?
Yeah, you can find this survey on Good Smile USA's Twitter account.
So please let them know what you want to see from them, be it FUWAMOCO or maybe your favorite anime characters too.
Yeah, okay!
Let's continue to love figures lots and lots, okay Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Recently we've been kind of looking at figures a bit more, Ruffians.
It's just so wonderful to have like a living representation of what you really are.
I know.
To be able to see at all different angles.
Pero figure.
You don't need a Pero figure.
There's not a lot of angles there.
No.
Okay.
Just curves.
BAU BAU!
Wow.
There's a bit of an update, Ruffians.
Update, a bit of a BAU BAU.
Well, it seems like Matsuri-senpai, like her BAU BAU view is kinda getting a bit bad again.
Yeah, her condition isn't looking too good.
It's not looking good, Ruffians.
During a chatting stream she had just the other day, she was mentioning how she likes licking the fingers of other hololive members.
Uh, yeah.
But, she said that she could never do that to FUWAMOCO.
That she just wants to observe us, not touch.
That's probably for the best!
Yeah.
I don't know what might happen if Matsuri-senpai wants to try to like us.
At the very least, you know running.
Running is an option.
An option?
But I don't know if violence might accidentally occur either.
That's a way to describe it.
Yeah.
You know, originally we thought that maybe there might be senpai trying to touch our ears or tails.
We didn't expect there to be senpai who would think about trying to lick our fingers.
That wasn't a concern, but now... It's a bit of a concern!
If Matsuri-senpai wants to watch us from afar though, does that make her a wall too?
Does Matsuri-senpai want to be a mom or a wall?
Our wall mom?
What is it?
Well, now we'll be surrounded by two walls, you know.
A Rui-senpai wall and a Matsuri-senpai wall.
Yeah.
Soon we'll have so many walls we could build a house.
BAU BAU!
Matsuri-senpai, please feel better.
Better?
Better soon.
Good luck!
If you think of Rui-ne-senpai as a wall and Matsuri-senpai as a wall, they're very different walls though, right?
Towa.
Smawa.
Wawa.
Wanderwa.
What?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You know FUWAMOCO.
We're Ruffians.
We're fuzzy.
We're FUWAMOCO, right?
But you also know of Moco-chan's special power.
Right!
My special power.
Right?
Ruffians!
The power to sneeze, yeah!
Extraordinary sneezes!
It took you a while.
It did.
Well, it turns out that Moco-chan's almost at a total of 200 on-stream sneezes!
Yeah!
In six months, not even!
That's nothing to sneeze at, right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
If that's not extraordinary, then I don't know what is, huh?
Yeah, but, uh, Ruffians... I don't know.
Slowly, it seems like Moco-chan's sneezes are kind of being thought of as a given or normal.
You know, it's just something that happens.
It's a normal everyday FUWAMOCO's dream.
Hmm.
Ruffians.
Do you not like my sneezes anymore?
Just because it isn't rare done.
You don't want it.
It's not something to celebrate because it's just commonplace everyday stuff now.
Would it be better for me not to sneeze?
Should I just mute what I feel when coming on?
Does it gross you out now?
I get it.
Nothing that I do is special anymore, huh?
That's how it is, huh?
I get it.
Well, I guess I'll aim for 200.
And then, maybe then, I'll retire from being the strongest sneezer in all of hololive, okay?
Retire?
I guess that's how it has to be, huh?
BAU BAU.
Well, it's good that you've made your decision, huh Moco-chan?
Ruffians!
Moco-chan's came to a decision.
It's just commonplace.
It's just normal.
It's kind of gross, actually.
That's how you think, huh?
BAU BAU!
I hope I can do something that seems special to you, okay?
I hope!
It happens.
Just like the misunderstandings, huh?
Where did they go after all?
I don't know, that's the biggest mystery of 2024.
But!
Well, Ruffians, you know that this week, we had a double watch-along.
We watched the Kanon anime, right?
Yeah, we did!
Unsurprisingly, it made us cry lots and lots and lots.
We also briefly mentioned another show that makes us cry a lot too.
That show is Hajimete no Otsukai!
Have you heard of it before, Ruffians?
I think it's called Old Enough Overseas.
Hajimete no Otsukai.
It's a TV show that we really really like.
It has been running for many years in Japan.
Explain a bit about it.
It's a show that follows a little kid's first errand that they go on all alone without their parents.
So a parent would be like, go get me some rice and go on this path.
Get some miso.
Ask the grandpa for a fish and make sure you get this kind of fish, that kind of thing.
But a lot of the kids, they're only 3 or 4 years old.
So little rice!
Mine's so tiny!
It's really cute and heartwarming.
But... It also makes us teary.
We were watching it the other day together!
And it's just too cute.
It's so cute!
Yeah, it made us kind of think about that kind of life and we started talking about a lot of silly things like, FUWAMOCO if we were parrots!
You know, I always get very curious seeing the mom and dad all emotional and excited and happy throughout the show.
You know, them working so hard to control themselves too.
And I just like, wait... DAD!
MOM!
BAU BAU!
You know, there was mention of us having two soccer teams for puppies way back, right?
No.
Back when we debuted.
No, that's not happening!
That's not happening.
No, that's not happening.
Sometimes it's nice to imagine having your own cute little kids to love and take care of.
But...
In the end, cats are good too.
Cats are good too.
And then you know, fluffy fluffy.
They will go anywhere if you don't let them.
And then if you get a little bit too hungry then...
To summarize, Hajimete no Otsukai is a very powerful show, making us a bit silly.
BAU BAU!
Let's continue on to our regular corner, Shiroppo-chan.
Today, we have our Doggie of the Day.
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
Today's Doggie of the Day is Loki!
Too cute!
Such a big smile!
And such a pretty chew!
He's apparently the baby of the family.
I can tell.
His nose!
The fluffy chest!
Very very cute.
He has the milky stripe!
Milky stripe!
How does Loki BAU BAU?
I don't know, I think he's...
I'm coming too!
I'm Loki!
Loki is just a baby still
Because below him, he'll be a baby forever and ever.
Especially with that cute smile.
Please give him lots of head pats from us, okay?
BAU BAU!
So cute!
And win!
Today I went on a walk.
We have De-den!
Is this a vacation?
On a hike?
This is quite different from all the snowy walks we've been doing.
It's nice that this is a place you can go on a hike, right?
We are.
You know.
You know we're stumbling upon a beautifully hidden beach.
I don't know.
It sure seems like a vacation spot.
Romantic!
Romantic vacation.
Not vacation.
It's so pretty.
I wanna go too.
A hidden beach with sand.
We could find a mermaid.
We could be the mermaid.
I'm the mermaid, Ruffians okay!
Be the mermaid!
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day.
And for our Question of the Day we have... De-den!
BAU BAU!
I'm curious about for how long can FUWAMOCO hold their breath for?
Mococo's crazy for a get-to and endless BAU BAUs must require a lung capacity only achievable by the best Demon Guard Dogs.
Wow.
I think it varies depending on how much we slept and everything.
You know, and how much... You know what sort of state we're in.
I don't know, I feel like right now is not the best, but we'll give it a good shot.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh wait, I started too early.
Okay, one more time.
Okay, Moco-chan.
No, I'm not.
You count down.
3, 2, 1.
I didn't want to lose to you, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
I won!
You won?
No fair!
Yeah.
I feel like we can do better for sure.
I think so too.
Almost one minute!
Really?
Wow.
The long silence.
You know, we hope we can improve our lung capacity so we can sing better in the future too.
Yeah, I feel like most people you don't think about lung capacity being important, but to us it's very very important.
And that's why I don't think it's very good right now.
Yeah.
But we know we're gonna make sure that we can put more of a priority on our physical health too, right?
More!
Up the lung capacity.
Up the stats.
Up the stamina.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you make sure to chill, okay?
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Your doggies, your questions, your Pero Sightings, and your walks, too.
Make sure you continue to go on walks, but be safe when you go out, okay?
That will help your lung capacity, too.
Very slowly, but yes.
Daily walks, you know?
And then you'll get there.
Please don't forget to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING or FWMC for the scoops.
FWMC scoop for the scoops!
Okay!
Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
And for our next stream, we have... Abyss Karaoke Relay!
The very first Karaoke Relay.
will be happening today.
It will start over on our channel first.
We have the schedule.
Our channel first will be doing an Archive Karaoke.
And then after that we'll be continuing on to Shiori, then to Biboo, then to Nerissa, and then back to us.
We'll be starting it.
You know, I think a bunch of our favorite songs, your favorite maybe, and you know, we'll just have a really fun time singing all together with Advent today.
Please join us, okay?
I'm so excited.
BAU BAU!
Actually, I kind of hope we sing the same songs too.
Oh, as other...
Advent Memories!
You know, you can kind of see how each member puts a spin on things.
I don't know if that's going to happen, but... We don't know.
We'll have to see!
BAU BAU!
And for our schedule!
Wow, this weekend we have a number of streams, but first!
It's been a while, but we'll be doing a Japanese stream!
We'll be doing a game called Make Takoyaki, but there's been a lot of rumors that FUWAMOCO is from Kansai.
We want to prove to everyone if FUWAMOCO is from Kansai or not!
We're going to be playing Tsukute!
Make it Takoyaki!
We're going to be chatting a lot in Japanese.
It's a 3am PT, so it's a little bit early, but not on a schedule.
We're also going to be streaming at 6pm PT as always.
We're going to be playing Thief Simulator 2.
Thief Simulator 2!
2 Thieves!
FUWAMOCO!
And we're gonna be borrowing some Dreamcasts and GameCubes and anything else, you know, that's kind of... Maybe your PSP.
Right.
And then on Sunday, we're gonna be playing Touhou Fujii no Kun!
For the first time together with you, Ruffians, we see just how amazing we are at Touhou as we don't play on Lunatic Mode.
Not Lunatic Mode.
But let's see how much we improve, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning for the 70th episode!
Wow, that's really good.
We're looking forward to many, many more mornings together with you.
Six months of FUWAMOCO Morning, it's gone really fast, and we're sure the next 70 episodes will go really fast too!
How has it gone so fast?
I really don't know.
How have we done this 70 times?
I don't know.
Somehow!
Thank you so much, Moco!
Thank you!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
GenGen!
BAU BAU!
TaroTaro!
Maishi!
BAU BAU!
Amem.
Kitsuneko.
BAU BAU!
Slymon.
Senti.
BAU BAU!
Abaihouki.
No Jumping.
BAU BAU!
Giant Rat.
Damian Itami.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was the 70th episode.
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!